this two-dimensional creature has locked  some precious gems away in a safe she's  checked the safe from every angle and is  sure that no one will be able to break  in without a key but she hasn't taken  into account the idea that a  three-dimensional creature such as  myself might be peering in from above  she doesn't even know the concept of  above  I could steal these gems without a key  and without damaging the safe and she  would have no idea how they were taken  but we should keep an eye out for  ourselves a four-dimensional creature  could steal from our safes without a key  could take the yolk from an egg without  breaking the shell  appear in a closed room or see inside of  our brains the fourth dimension is  perpendicular to all of our normal 3D  space directions and we have no walls up  against that direction